SPEAKER: Play music jazz.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Our
cars guess where
we're going, while our
phones keep us connected.
The android auto development
course from Udacity,
built in collaboration
with Google,
will show you how
making your android app
available in the car is as
easy as extending your existing
coat.
The course focuses on plain
audio and handling messages
so that your users can stay
connected with their hands
on the wheel and
eyes on the road.
Take a road trip with us to
learn how to expose content,
control playback, and customize
the UI for playing audio.
As well as how to show
notifications, playback
messages, and reply by voice.
Follow this link
to get started now.